corporations are in a constant state of
competition with each other the bottom
line is profit and whatever strategies
they can use to get it they'll do either
through consumer research competitive
pricing or improving product quality
for example McDonald's and Burger King
both jumped on the vegan bandwagon by
making meatless burgers
however strategies like these tend to
require lots of invested time and
capital which can make this strategy
somewhat unattractive sometimes instead
of putting their nose to the grindstone
so to speak companies simply choose to
market their product differently this is
done by treading a very fine line of
deception and honesty oftentimes
marketing borders on the line of facts
that are too good to be true during the
early 1960s the American Cancer Society
published several landmark studies that
conclusively proved smoking tobacco was
a direct cause of lung cancer how did
cigarette companies respond did they
invest time and capital into making a
healthier product no they pivoted to the
medical findings by simply marketing
their cigarettes as healthy alternatives
to other tobacco companies this was best
illustrated on the TV show Mad Men where
ad executive Don Draper creates an ad
campaign for the cigarette company Lucky
Strikes to counter the damaging reports
the Federal Trade Commission and
Reader's Digest have done you a favor
they've lets you know that any ad that
brings up the concept of cigarettes and
health together well it's just gonna
make people think of cancer if you can't
make those health claims neither can
your competitors so we got a lot of
people not saying anything that sells
cigarettes not exactly this is the
greatest advertising opportunity since
the invention of cereal we have six
identical companies making six identical
products we can say anything we want how
do you make your cigarettes we breathe
insect repellant tobacco seized land
them in the North Carolina sunshine grow
it cut it cure it
toast it what are you going to there you
go
but everybody else is tobacco's toast
know everybody else's tobacco is
poisonous Lucky Strikes is toasted as in
all things including marketing other
cigarette companies followed suit and
began advertising their cigarettes as
healthy alternatives
long story short companies have always
been to the truth on the quality or
performance of their products just to
have an edge in the market this scenario
with cigarette companies is a rough
template that can be reflected in how
shampoo companies have recently
advertised their products you see I'm
just a simple youtuber I harbor science
content when I see it and when I notice
a crop of bad science being marketed to
consumers
I see it's ready for the plucking to
avoid the unwanted blowback of saying
not nice things about multi-million
dollar shampoo companies I'm not saying
these hygiene products that market my
sour shampoo caused cancer or are bad
for your health
I'm simply pointing out the alleged
science used to market the products
recently there has been a wave of
commercials pushing the concept of my
sour shampoo and for someone like me who
doesn't even know what brand of shampoo
he uses to notice this is kind of a big
deal which means it must be a pretty
large campaign new Pantene micellar
series with my seller technology that
helps to deep cleanse and detox daily
dirt and grime toxin nourish for free
flowing hair new Pantene my seller
series ok so what's the issue my seller
shampoo is nothing new advanced or
different from any other kind of shampoo
on the market this is because my shower
shampoo is an intrinsic property of all
shampoo and really any kind of hygiene
product that you use to wash your body
let me explain all soap and shampoo are
made up of molecules called fatty acids
but for simplicity we'll just call them
soap molecules these soap molecules have
two distinct chemical structures to them
that allow them to clean your body one
end of the molecule is hydrophilic that
is it's attracted to water and the other
end is hydrophobic and is therefore
attracted to oils and grease when the
soap molecules are immersed in a mixture
of water and grease much like in a dirty
frying pan the hydrophobic ends grouped
together around the oil and the
hydrophilic ends face outward toward the
water
this arrangement forms a spherical
aggregate of soap molecules this sphere
of molecules is called on my cell which
is how we get my
Celer shampoo it turns out this property
is extremely useful for removing oil and
grease from a surface micelles are
present in anything you use to clean
whether it be detergent to wash clothes
dish soap to wash dishes or shampoo to
wash your hair you can't wash away all
with just water because oil and water
don't mix you need something that will
capture the oil which is micelles so
what exactly makes these my sour shampoo
products so special well nothing much
like how Lucky Strikes provide a false
premise with their cigarettes as being
healthy alternatives because they were
toasted companies that push my sour
sampoo are also giving a disingenuous
premise to the consumer again this is
because the micellar property is claimed
to be in their bottle of shampoo are
ubiquitous in all shampoo it's really no
different than saying hey buy this
bottle of orange juice because it has
vitamin C in it but all orange juice
already has vitamin C in its crap guten
tag so we've all seen them those chic
Parisian women with their effortless
beauty and flawless skin and hair so how
do they do it through sexually selective
genes one indispensable product in their
beauty ritual is my solar water now this
magical elixir is long popular in France
oh yeah because some important products
are superior which means they have to
say the magical my solar water is also
important and apparently from France
from a creative standpoint this is lazy
marketing full disclosure water from
friends does not have my soror
properties and to say that it does
implies water from France is soapy so
what is my slur micelle is a tiny and
powerful molecule no it's not it's an
aggregate of soap molecules this is a
single soap molecule this is an
aggregation of multiple soap molecules
this is a flock of birds this is a bird
they act like a magnet drawing out
impurities dirt and oil and
environmental pollutants hey that's
really great except every shampoo in the
world already does us hello now
oh look they got a German scientist
perfect yeah with the lab coat and the
glasses and I am in charge of developing
hair care products expats come
professional our BC shampoos containing
the micellar technology micellar
technology on the back when you see the
hair fiber is all impurities on it
when using the cleansing products the
micellar water works like a magnet on
your hair attracting and capturing all
the impurities pretty much it's like any
other shampoo unfortunately it's a sad
truth that companies will take advantage
of customers just to maintain a bottom
line i'll admit myself it's difficult to
avoid gimmicks like this especially when
they use fancy and intimidating science
just to fool you all that you can do as
a consumer to avoid falling victim to
sleazy marketing is if something seems
too good to be true it probably is
and most products are going to be more
or less the same with slightly different
levels of performance which at that
point comes down to your own preference
[Music]
you